what were your experiences with James
Dean working on the well you know he was
very young then he was very quiet and
kind of came in he didn't talk too much
to anybody he was always in his you know
his shirt like in squares and just like
that all the time he was a rock with the
head as you said the Bria Goss play with
the rock and I always thought you know
what is he doing with that little thing
doing like that and I could I understood
what was happening but you know later
all right you understood when he was
around oh no oil well and you know it's
incredible to see him do that rope stunt
very well you know he really was getting
into his role in a very powerful way and
they were always working on his role and
well he was a little bit strange this
boy for me okay this I said well what is
what is going on what happened with him
and he used to get near me and talk to
our three words not too much yeah just a
little bit and when I was very same it
and I could call him speak English I
don't speak English now but I speak more
than then and and I said well you know
and one day he came over me and said
Elsa will you be so kind to translate
this to me he hate he hand me a letter
and I said well he was related to from
spanish to english and i said my god
what am I gonna do if I honey can speak
English so he gave me the letter he
wasn't Italian he was
it was not in Spanish so myself and the
letter was from pier Angeli I saw it is
that July I didn't invent it so I start
to read that thing and well I couldn't
know I understood a little bit because
Italian a little bit is like Spanish but
not really no it's very different it's
different so I translate little what I
could do at the time and well it was
pier Angeli that later on I learned he
was in love with she was in you know he
was in love with her yes and I had that
experience and how about you know did
you have any scenes with Elizabeth
Taylor yes I had the one in the car when
we were singing south of the border yes
the one of the hotel yeah remember the
one is the restaurant where they rotten
and owner of the restaurant had the big
fight yes which is a fantastic scene
it's so it's one of the most fantastic
things I ever seen in the movie yeah
it's a movie wonderful
the she's so dominating in the movie you
know and so powerful it's hard to
believe that she's like 24 and in a way
you know when she's older she's even
stronger
you know she plays that so so powerfully
what we her memories of her and and the
way she would perform oh I just love it
you know the first time I went into the
set in Hollywood when I already had
hired me so I went there and then we're
having a scene where she came down the
stairs with a kind of purple dress
beautiful I think then we when she met
Rock Hudson yes and I just couldn't
believe how beautiful that woman was she
looked like something out of this world
you know going down the stairs
and I never forget I never will forget
that scene III don't think she's so
beautiful in this movie III don't think
anyone has ever forgotten how beautiful
she was in this well I think she was
beautiful all her movies yes she was